it's one of the world's largest coral
systems made up of nearly 3,000 separate
reefs and 900 Islands the Great Barrier
Reef attracts huge numbers of tourists
every year but this underwater treasure
is at risk of disappearing due to coral
bleaching caused by rising temperatures
over the past two weeks James Cook
University has surveyed more than a
thousand reefs it found they were
severely bleached in all three regions
of the system and says it's more
widespread than ever before this is the
third time it's happened in the past
five years if this continues and we're
seeing these mass bleaching events every
few years that just will not be the
opportunity for the corals to recover in
between these major disturbances when
water is too warm corals will expel
algae that causes them to bleach in
February the reef recorded its highest
sea surface temperature since records
began in 1900 while bleaching isn't
always fatal scientists say in severe
events like this many corals don't
survive it really is unprecedented and
we think about what the Great Barrier
gives Australia areas its cultural
heritage its iconic and the tourism
industry all of these facets we will
lose instantly if we have another
bleaching event of these magnitudes the
reef is highly vulnerable not only to
warming temperatures but also pollution
and coastal development
scientists say ocean temperatures over
the next month will be crucial to how
the reef recovers it's not just in the
sea where Australia is feeling the
effects of climate change of course
severe drought is intensifying push
fires and scientists are calling for
stronger climate policy from the
government to reduce emissions without
it they say the situation will only get
worse Nicola gage al Jazeera Sydney